a spate of anti-semitic attacks follows
hamas's war on israel while top
democrats condemn
islamophobia i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn your data is your business
protected
at expressvpn.com we'll get to all the
news in just
one moment first you can really save a
lot of money on your cell phone bill and
i haven't thought about this recently
but this
is the reality the fact is that if you
are with verizon or at t or t-mobile you
are
spending too much money and switching
over to pure talk usa
will in fact save you money in fact pure
talk saves the average family of four
over 800
a year here's the best part you don't
have to sacrifice coverage because it's
on the exact same network as one of
those providers
friends switching is easy you can keep
your phone keep your number get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids right now you can get
unlimited talk text six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month and
if you go over on data they don't charge
you for it it's just one of the many
reasons they've been named the top
wireless
provider by consumer affairs why
wouldn't you save yourself hundreds of
dollars a year
if you could well right now you can by
switching on over to puretalk
usa from your cell phone now pound 250
say
ben shapiro you'll save 50 off your very
first month that is pound two five zero
say ben shapiro to get started again
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro get
started with pure talk usa say 50
off your first month and hundreds of
bucks down the road because what you
need is not what all these big
cell phone providers are actually
promising you which is the moon instead
what you need is unlimited talk tech six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on data they're not
going to charge you for it check them
out pure talk usa dell pound
250 say ben shapiro also before we get
started
i do have a very important announcement
we are looking for a producer here at
daily wire that's right this is a senior
level positioned at our nashville hq
this could be you you can apply on our
website through dailywire.com
careers so if you have at least five
years of experience in broadcast
production
head on over to the website apply
dailywire.com
careers by the way should check that
site also because we have other jobs
that are open as well dailywire.com
careers alrighty so i want to begin
today
with a simple fact i worry yamaka
i've worn a yamaka since basically i'm
old enough to remember
and there are a lot of folks who ask me
why wariomac or why i didn't take off
the yamaka as i grew in my career and
the answer is because this is who i am
and this is what i do it never occurred
to me
to take off the yamaka and i've seen
over the course of the last week or so
this increase in anti-semitic attacks
and i know a rabbi
who over the weekend explained that
he was at a supermarket and a man
walked up to him and to his son wearing
a hamas headband and started
cursing him cursing the jews and so a
lot of people
ask why i wear a yamaka i don't talk
about this frequently the reason i'm
talking about it now is because i think
it's really really important to
understand
why jews wear a yamaka the reason the
jews were yama can make ourselves
identifiable right theoretically we
could hide although historically that
has not been
a winning strategy for jews the reason i
wear yamaka is for two reasons one
there's a religious reason going all the
way back to the talmud jews have warned
yama because they've covered their heads
out of submission to god and as a
reminder that god is above us at all
times
and the second reason is because no i'm
not going anywhere
and anybody who has a problem with it
can write off
okay the simple fact of the matter is
that i believe
in the promises that were made by god in
the bible i believe in those promises
i believe isaiah when he says isaiah 8
u28
i believe that when when isaiah says
plan your plan
speak your words it will come to nothing
for god is with us i believe that
because i believe in biblical values
i believe in the first book of samuel
where samuel says
israel and the eternal of israel the
eternal god of israel
is no lie and that means the eternity
of the bible and biblical values those
are no lie either
i wear a yamaka because i am proudly a
descendant of
abraham and isaac and jacob and moses
and david i am of their people
i am of their ideals and of their values
and if you have a problem with it
not only do you have a problem with jews
you have a problem with the entire
judeo-christian line of values
i wear this yamaka because i am proud of
that identity
and you know what i'm proud that the
state of israel exists as well
i am proud that there is a state of
israel a state
that is a repository for jewish values i
am proud
that there are jews out there carrying
guns in defense of jews because for
thousands of years
that was not the case i am proud
as all civilized western people should
be that there is a state in the middle
east
that stands for the reality not only of
strong jews but stands for a
democratic truth stands for a democratic
state
and you've heard that israel is some
sort of apartheid state let me give you
a quick stat okay here is the number of
jews in israel right now 1.9
million arabs in the jewish state of
israel
okay there are nine million people total
in the state of israel 1.9 million do
you know how many jews there are
in all of these so-called non-apartheid
states surrounding israel
there are a grand total of 10 jews in
egypt population
100 million there are zero jews in
jordan population 10 million
zero jews in saudi arabia population 34
million
100 jews in lebanon population 7 million
zero jews in syria population 17 million
four jews in iraq population 39 million
8 300 jews in iran population
83 million how many jews are there
living
under the wonderful auspices of the
palestinian authority
population 2.7 million zero how many are
living
under the tender mercies of the
terrorist group hamas in the gaza strip
zero there are two million people who
live under hamas
in israel twenty percent of the
population is arab
minimum and rising and that is because
israel is tolerant and israel is
democratic and i am proud of that
as a westerner i am proud of the fact
that israel is humane
in the middle of wars israel is
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties of a population that
supported hamas by pole statistics
that israel is attempting to avoid
killing civilians meanwhile its enemies
are attempting to shield their own
weapons with civilians
i am proud of the fact that israel
carries out its values in war and in
peace
and i'm proud of the fact that israel is
in fact
in an outlying area of western democracy
not because it is some sort of
colonialist outpost but because the jews
never left and because the root of the
west remains
through that judeo-christian line i am
proud of all those things
and because i'm proud of all those
things as an american and as a jew
i wear this yamaka and if you have a
problem with this you can
write off and i mean that to all the
semi to
the anti-semites who are out there all
the anti-semites
who want to suggest that jews
everywhere should be living in fear of
wearing a yamaka or speaking their
values
which happen to be correct values
everyone out there who suggests that if
you support israel you deserve
to be treated as a second-class citizen
or that israel itself ought to be
treated as a second-class country
i wear the yamaha because i stand
against all of that
and i know that there are tons of people
who are not jewish who believe the same
things that i do
and i'm so grateful for that i get your
notes
i get your letters of support i get that
the vast majority of americans
understand the truth
not only with regard to the israel arab
conflict
which of course is a foreign conflict
but also
they understand the underlying truth
about the nature
of jews living in the united states and
the reality of jewish values
and i say all of this to say that if
people fail to recognize
these basic truths that judeo-christian
values undergird
american values and western values and
liberties that we all enjoy
if people fail to recognize the basic
decency
of one state attempting to minimize
civilian casualties while another
terrorist group attempts to wipe every
jewish can off the planet
that if people fail to recognize this
and if they in fact forward this agenda
and if they cheer that agenda they are
complicit in the anti-semitic attacks
that we have seen
over the course of these weekends i'm
not saying they're responsible for those
attacks unless they openly call for them
because i have a very strict standard
when it comes to quote unquote
incitement
but you have raised the temperature
you've made it more comfortable
and that is what i am seeing okay i have
close relatives who live in new jersey
people in jews in new jersey were told
over the course of this weekend
that they were supposed to stay in their
homes over sabbath
that is un-american i have a lot of
friends in new york
who are walking around in groups because
they are afraid to walk around alone in
the city of new york in the united
states
these attacks are not fake these attacks
are not rare
jews historically in the united states
have been the number one target
of hate crimes in the united states but
that's constantly forgotten because of
course we now live in a world in which
victimization
can be linked to your historical
dispossession so long
as your group is not well educated and
wealthy in the same way that
anti-anti-asian
sentiment went completely by the wayside
for years because
asian americans tend to be well-educated
and wealthy anti-semitism has gone by
the wayside
unless it's a convenient club with which
to
beat people on the right the reality
today
is that institutionalized anti-semitism
lives on the american left
the truth is that the spate of
anti-semitic attacks that we've seen
over the course of the last week
is not coming from white supremacists
white supremacists are scary enough
believe me i've spoken up about them
just a couple of years ago the fbi
arrested a white supremacist attempting
to threaten and hurt my family
but the threat that we have seen over
the last week people in the streets
going around attempting to beat jews
that is not coming from white
supremacists
that is coming from a
a radical a radicalized islamic
population
backed by the american left in many ways
so let's get into what exactly happened
over the weekend
and so over the course of the last week
several jews in new york have been
beaten up
by palestinian mobs here is one jew
talking about that experience over the
course of the last week
walking on the way had my yamaka on my
keeper and
around 48th street at corner of my eye i
see someone chasing me
before i could even react i was
surrounded by a whole group of
you know individuals who then proceeded
to you know kick me
punch me hit me with crutches beat me
with like flag poles
i've seen videos in la i've seen videos
in london and you think it could happen
anywhere
but you know when it actually happens
like
personally even more so than to someone
you know it's really just like
shakespeare world up a little bit to be
honest i mean it's it's incredible and
let me just point
out something he says you know i was
just wearing a yamaka and people
identified me as zionist and as
pro-israel because i was wearing a
yamaka
okay number one there are some jews who
are not but
put that aside the reality is that in
the united states of america if you're
wearing
a yarmulke or if you're wearing a shirt
that says i stand with israel
that doesn't mean there's now an excuse
to beat the hell out of you
if you were wearing a shirt that says i
support palestine you don't have a right
in the united states
to beat somebody up or be beaten up
this is insane but there is this feeling
out there that has become quite
predominant on the radical left that if
you support israel
in any way shape or form that you
deserve to have this done to you
it's it's sick it is a sickness
according to fox news nypd hate crimes
division said saturday it's
investigating two more incidents
targeting jewish people in new york city
that appears to be prompted by the
recent israel-palestinian conflict by
the way quick note i checked the new
york times webpage
last night i checked their whole page no
mention of any of this the washington
post did have a story on it that is
their first story i believe in a week
the new york times had nothing as of
last night
two jewish teenagers were reportedly
surrounded by an angry mob with baseball
bats around six or seven pm saturday on
ocean parkway and 18th avenue in
brooklyn
the crowd demanded that the teens chant
free palestine before beating them
because nothing says there's no need for
a jewish state anymore
quite like beating up random jews in the
streets makes perfect sense
the same people who are saying if there
were no israel there would be no
anti-semitism are literally beating up
jews in the streets
i don't believe you i think you are
lying
i think you just hate jews jeff heiken
is the former state assemblyman and
founder of the grassroots coalition
americans against anti-semitism
he said in a tweet that the teens were
saved by a muslim uber driver
who drove them to safety another
incident in brooklyn
on saturday involved orthodox jews were
reportedly harassed in front of a
synagogue on 16th avenue by a group of
males yelling free palestine
kill all the jews i have friends in los
angeles who over the holiday of shavuot
last week were walking home from
synagogue and people drove by shouting
free palestine at them
and allahu akbar so wonderful things
happening all over the united states
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that my kids wake me up extraordinarily
early in the morning and that means i
need my coffee i didn't used to be a
coffee drinker my kids have made me a
coffee drinker and the coffee that i
prefer is black rifle coffee
they're delivering your daily dose of
freedom in one delicious cup at a time
black rifle coffee company
is a veteran-owned coffee company
serving premium coffee to people who
love america
veterans ceo and founder evan hafer
spent over seven years on the ground
overseas with u.s
special forces and as a cia contractor
black rifle is continually committed to
supporting veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes in our country and overseas
courageous frontline workers risk their
lives every day to protect ours inspired
by their hard work and dedication to
protecting our communities black rifle
makes it their mission to give back to
those who serve however they can
throughout may black rifle is rallying
behind leo law enforcement officers
firefighters first responders active
duty military other front line workers
by spotlighting local heroes through
community nominations donating coffee to
keep the front lines caffeinated and
giving back to organizations that
support our nation's heroes
black rifle imports their high-quality
coffee beans from all over the world
and rose five days a week at their
facilities in manchester tennessee and
salt lake city utah they make excellent
excellent coffee man and they're great
dudes as well go to
use promo code blackriflecoffee.com get
20 off your purchase and
your first coffee club order that is
blackriflecoffee.com shapiro promo code
shapiroblackriflecoffee.com
shapiro promo code shapiro to get
started
okay so all of that is happening in
new york also new york having some of
the world's
worst criminal law enforcement at this
point
they have now released a man who
beat up a jew in midtown manhattan
according to the post-millennial a man
arrested in connection to the beating of
a jewish man in midtown manhattan was
released on bail thursday
telling prosecutors on sunday he would
do it again
he said openly he would do it again he
was released on bail because this is new
york now
wasim awada 23 was held on ten thousand
dollars bill after being accused of
beating
joseph borgian with crutches as well as
punching kicking and pepper spraying the
man that was the first person we quoted
today
a wod according to a special pro at a
prosecutor at his sunday arraignment in
manhattan
reportedly told one of his jailers if i
could do it again i would do it again
by the way when he was when he was
arrested he was wearing a shirt
that just it said free palestine it was
the entire map of israel because when
people say free palestine understand
they don't mean the west bank and the
gaza strip they don't mean jude and
samaria in the gaza strip
they mean all of it prosecutors say the
attack on borgian
who was walking near broadway and west
49th street on his way to a pro-israel
demonstration in midtown was unprovoked
by the way broadway and west 49th street
is not a bad area of new york
i know they're now all bad areas of new
york but this is like right near times
square
friends of water told the new york post
he was the one that was attacked first
they picked somebody that was weak that
was on crutches one stated uh-huh
he sure he said he would do it again i'm
sure that's right
awada is facing charges of assault as a
hate crime gang assault menacing
aggravated harassment as a hate crime
and criminal possession of a weapon uh
save the police morgan was walking down
the street sporting a keeper when a man
started running at me or running at him
he said i turned around to try to figure
out what was going on
the next thing i knew i was surrounded
by a whole crowd of people who proceeded
to physically
attack me and he has a concussion by the
way
so really solid stuff happening in new
york
speaking of which luca robert davis a 20
year old rookie goalie for the new york
red bulls major league soccer team said
on thursday new york city he was
accosted by a group of six to eight
palestinian men
who accosted him and asked him if he was
jewish as they brandished knives
according to the daily wire
lewis wrote that when he said he was not
jewish one of the men said
good but when was prompted what if i was
jewish the man got in his face saying
i'd beat the effing bleep out of you and
kill you
this is what he wrote on instagram
again wonderful things happening in new
york but it's not just in new york
an armed citizen had to intervene in
miami according to breitbart
and fox news on may 21 fox news reported
that eric organ and his family were
walking down the sidewalk in the ball
harbor neighborhood which is a heavily
jewish neighborhood of miami
when a group of men allegedly pulled up
in a vehicle and started shouting and
throwing garbage at them
oregon told cbs 12 that the men in the
vehicle also allegedly screamed
free palestine died you a few jew i'm
going to rape your wife
an armed citizen in another vehicle saw
it was happening and then intervened
so thank god this is florida so there
were actual consequences to this sort of
stuff oregon says the guy in the car
behind them saw everything go on i saw
him pull a gun and get in between
i mean he was almost there as our
guardian angel just protecting us i
think once they saw him they just took
off by the way it is worthwhile noting
i'm in south florida what's happening
these pro-palestinian crowds
these demonstrators who are running
around chanting anti-semitic slogans
they're going specifically to jewish
areas they're not going to legislative
areas and talking to legislators they're
going to the most
jewish areas they can find in south
florida in an attempt to intimidate
carrying around pure anti-semitic hate
slogans
in many cases so that's if you're
running around jewish areas carrying
around anti-medicaid slogans basically
you're the nazis walking through skokie
right you've just decided to identify a
jewish area and then try to intimidate
everybody that you can which is
disgusting but unfortunately
not rare four u.s synagogues were
vandalized in the past week
not by white supremacists not by white
supremacists believe me
i have enough hatred to go around for
the white supremacists and they have
enough hatred for me
what we are seeing on the streets what
we've seen in europe is not white
supremacists predominantly
what we are seeing right now is radical
islamists who are going around
attempting to beat
intimidate and threaten jews
meanwhile over in europe you're seeing
exactly that
over in london tens of thousands of
people showed up
to protest basically the existence of
the state of israel carrying
anti-semitic slogans
a man standing on a lion statue in
traffic or square yesterday held a
palestinian flag beneath him a placard
read stop doing what hitler did to you
a poster held up by a woman read israel
the new nazi state right the go
this is all anti-semitic bull crap
obviously you're literally talking about
israel
facing down a terrorist group that
openly pledged in 1988
in its charter documents to kill every
jew it could find but don't worry the
jews defending themselves
those are the those are the anti-semites
those are those are the hitlerian
genocidal people it's crazy
and meanwhile people are walking through
the streets of london accompanied by the
police
chanting that they would like to hunt
jews this is video from just over the
weekend
[Music]
we'll find some screws
okay so it's just wonder and joy out
there it's just
truly wonderful stuff so what has been
the response
of the mainstream left increasingly the
response to the mainstream left is
either been a coward and a corner or to
make excuses for this sort of stuff
because there's a basic logic that
predominates and that is that if you're
a jew wearing a yamaka
it must be that as a supporter of israel
which you probably are
not all are but virtually all orthodox
jews support the existence of the state
of israel
not just because they're jewish but also
because they believe in the common
values of the west and the state of
israel
as an american that is what i believe
okay but the
idea is that if you support israel
somehow you deserve what's coming to you
that's what's so amazing you'll see
people say
well you know what if you're shouting
bad things at the jews
but they're about israel then that's
just anti-zionism it's not anti-semitism
weird how the same exact people who are
expressing anti-zionist zionism are
willing to beat jews with pipes
apparently weird how that crossover is
strange
almost like a venn diagram that looks
just like a circle
the crossover is 100 virtually
it's it's an amazing thing so what has
been the response from the left
to poopoo this stuff and to take sides
with hamas now again what's amazing
truly about this particular conflict is
this is not even
about the drawing of borders between for
example
the palestinian authority and the
israeli authorities it's not about that
this is not about the legal case that
was happening in shiite this is about a
terrorist group
firing an american state department
designated terrorist group firing
rockets
at civilians in israel israel making
pinpoint attacks in an attempt to knock
out their infrastructure
and hundreds of thousands of people
marching in the streets to say that
israel shouldn't exist as a response
and a bunch of leftists in american life
and abroad
saying that israel is the problem here
if you believe israel is the problem in
a conflict between an actual
genocidal terrorist group and israel let
me just say you're an anti-semite
okay because there really is no other
rationale you're gonna have to explain
the rationale as to why you are siding
with the genocidal terrorist group that
by the way is subjecting
two million citizens in the gaza strip
to a perfect form
of absolute tyranny in which gay people
are killed and informers are murdered
and it's it's an incredible thing
i've never seen a clearer moral conflict
than hamas an actual terrorist group
being backed by the radical left
and people in order to justify that poo
pooing
islamist attacks on jews around the
world
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about simple fact
if you happen to have a medical problem
if you have a medical issue you should
just go get it solved there's no reason
to sit around
waiting on it with roman you get a free
online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan
if medication is appropriate it ships to
you free with two day shipping the whole
process is straightforward and discreet
getting started is super simple just go
to getroman.com
ben complete an online visit take care
of your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today connect
with a healthcare professional and get
it taken
care of head on over to getroman.com
right now you'll get 15 bucks off your
very first month of ed treatment
it's time to take care of that ed don't
just wait around hope it's gonna go away
instead you've got a medical problem
go get it solved remember get started
today you'll save 15 bucks on your very
first order
of edtreatment that is getroman.com once
more
getroman.com you get 15 bucks off your
very first month
g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-dot-com ben
right now and get that ed problem solved
instead of waiting around and hoping it
goes away
getroman.com ben okay so
what has been the mainstream left's
response to all of this well
first the media basically attempted to
ignore all of it so the new york times
all of last week paid no attention to
the anti-semitic attacks that had been
happening in its own state that's not a
shock right we saw bill de blasio
suggest that there was no anti-semitism
in his city just like
two years ago when jews were routinely
being beaten in the streets of
williamsburg
we saw the left act as though there was
no anti-semitism anywhere in the new
york new jersey area
when there was an actual black hebrew
israelite terrorist attack
on jews in new jersey oh where did this
come from
okay like orthodox jews can tell you
exactly where it came from since they're
the ones getting beaten in the streets
of williamsburg
it's an amazing amazing so the first
response is just ignore it
the second response is to come out in
strong defense
of people who have been raising the
temperature and telling the same
anti-semitic lies that act as fodder for
people who actually commit these sorts
of attacks
so black let me be clear about this one
of the things that has been happening in
terms of the
upswing in street violence that we are
seeing right now is a broader thing
happening across
american society in the wake of last
year's decision by cities across the
nation
to basically tell the cops not to police
radicals
of virtually every front have decided
that it's open season
after a year of black lives matter
protesters devolving into riots and
people committing high levels of street
crime
and murder rising by 30 percent in
america's major cities and
beatings going unprosecuted and and
criminals being unmolested by the cops
it turns out a lot of people think they
can get away with nearly anything
those two things are not unrelated when
you remove the cops from the situation
chaos ensues and usually the people who
pay the price very often when chaos
ensues when law enforcement don't do
their jobs
when people who are bad feel that they
can go out and do whatever they want
jews very often pay the price for that
historically speaking
but it's more than that on an
ideological level the radical left has
decided
that there is a commonality between
black lives matter for example
and and palestinian terror groups in
some cases
there's a whole article in the
washington post black lives matter
activists recently took to the streets
of indianapolis to protest for
palestinians
in congress a lawmaker who cut her teeth
as a black lives matter organizer and
who has compared her clashes with police
to those faced by palestinians tweeted
friday a ceasefire ends the bombardment
not the violence during the height of
the recent gaza hostilities the official
black lives matter organization called
for quote unquote palestinian
liberation six years after the group's
early leaders took a trip to the middle
east that planted the seeds for the
current alliance by the way when they
talk about palestinian liberation
understand you're talking about control
by the palestinian authority a terrorist
group hamas a terrorist group an islamic
jihadi terrorist group this was in
the black lives matter formula formative
documents it was on their website
to free palestine why because there's a
broader theory that i've been talking
about on the show
it goes all the way from france fanon
and forward and the basic idea
is that the systems of power in the west
benefit jews
okay there's a there's an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory on the left that
crosses streams
with mainstream leftist ideology
mainstream leftist ideologies that the
institutions of the west
create unequal outcomes and because
those institutions of the west create
unequal outcomes this means that anybody
who is successful
under those systems is a beneficiary of
the system and cannot be a victim and
anybody who is unsuccessful is
victimized by the system and cannot be
an oppressor
and so when you look at that
internationally what you see is that if
israel is very successful
this means that it must have oppressed
the palestinians even though israel
pulled it out of the gaza strip in 2005
16 years ago even though the vast
majority of palestinians live
under the auspices of the palestinian
authority which is their governing
agency
and they do not live under the under the
day-to-day administrative mercy
of the israelis they live under the
day-to-day administrative chaos of the
palestinian authority
which is the reason why israeli arabs
have not sought out migration
to palestinian areas they're not
interested they want to stay in israel
because israel actually governs its
citizens well
as opposed to its enemies but black
lives matter because again they buy into
this
basic international intersectionality
theory
whereby we can identify victimized
groups and victimizer groups by level of
success
this means that there's a commonality
between black lives matter and the
palestinian authority
and hamas and all of the people who
support the destruction of the state of
israel
black lives matter in the united states
which has grown into a potent political
force amid a national reckoning on race
has responded forcefully to the violence
in the mideast to extend its reach into
foreign policy according to the
washington post
pressing the democratic party to adopt a
dramatically different approach to the
long-standing israeli-palestinian
conflict
this of course is right the radical left
is pushing on the israeli-palestinian
conflict
because again there's this idea that if
we tear down systems of power this means
the jews fall too
there is simple crossover and how's the
mainstream left responded
to this delusional nonsense they've
responded by patting it on the head
so aipac the american israel public
affairs committee
wrongly called the quote unquote israel
lobby by its enemies
basically it's just the same as a as a
pro italy
pack in the united states or a pro-irish
pack in the united states they exist for
nearly every country in the united
states
in any case apac has been made this big
bugaboo by anti-semites across the
united states apac is really
quite a moderate organization is the
simple fact of it apac in fact was so
dominated by democrats at its top level
that during the obama administration
they didn't even
push for a vote on the iran deal it was
very controversial inside the halls of
apac in any case
aipac put out some ads pointing out that
ilhan omar is an anti-semite
all they did was quote her okay they put
out ads
in which for example omar's face was
superimposed onto hamas rockets
with texts that claims when israel
targets hamas representative omar calls
it an act of terrorism
that's correct because what she tweeted
was israeli airstrikes killing civilians
in gaza is an act of terrorism
they were not killing civilians in
targeted fashion they were attempting to
kill hamas members
elena omar knows that of course the
washington post defends ilhan omar
the ad distorted omar's tweet from last
week in which she said that israeli
airstrikes killing civilians in gaza not
hamas specifically or an act of death
the missiles were aimed at hamas members
okay so
i understand the washington post is just
the press office for anti-semite ilhan
omar but that's pretty incredible stuff
omar's office warned the company similar
issues images of her face with hamas
attacks have directly inspired death
threats against her so this is the way
that the left is going to play this is
that if you're a radical anti-semite
who de facto supports hamas i mean she
she literally has attempted to block aid
to israel's iron dome which is a
defensive technology preventing rockets
from falling in civilian areas
that if you do that then then you put an
ad out there then you're the real
problem
nancy pelosi came to omar's defense she
has not chided ilhan omar
she refused last year to condemn ilhan
omar after openly anti-semitic
statements
okay and nancy pelosi rushed to her
defense
omar's office has called on apac to
apologize
and her deputy communications director
isi bear breen
called the anti-muslim hate speech
apec said this is a fair and accurate
statement
okay the fact that then ilhan omar
called on facebook to remove it hey so
how did the rest of the democratic party
respond to all this so we've seen this
radical uptick in anti-semitic attacks
over the course of the last week
largely by palestinians and palestinian
supporters
so how have mainstream democrats
responded to this they responded to it
with the same kind of moral equivalence
that they were
so quick to decry when president trump
for example suggested that there were
problems on both sides in
charlottesville
right what they said and it's truly
incredible
they're all tweeting out on mass on
message that there's a radical increase
in anti-semitism and
islamophobia now can anyone show me any
evidence of increased anti-islamic
attacks over the course of the last week
any any it's
the answer is no because it's a lie what
they are saying is that if you are
pro-israel you are islamophobic and
therefore
it's not super anti-semitic if you are
attacked that's the logic here
and it's being put out there by every
radical democrat
every single one bernie sanders tweeted
this out he tweeted out we've recently
seen disturbing anti-semitic attacks and
a troubling rise in islamophobia
really where's that really if you're
committed to a future of equality and
peaceful coexistence please stand united
against anyone who promotes hatred of
any kind
it's unbelievable the same people who
rip on trump's rhetoric
that guy's rhetoric a guy took that
guy's rhetoric and shot up a bunch of
congress people and that was not even a
national story of more in a week
and now here he is after having
suggested that israel is essentially an
apartheid state
here he is oh well you know but we have
to let's worry about islamophobia ayanna
presley the adjunct member of the squad
the ringo starr of the squad
she tweeted out i strongly condemn the
rise in anti-semitism and islamophobia
we're seeing across the country and
islamophobia
now again any statistical data to
demonstrate that there's an increase in
islamophobia islamophobic attacks in the
united states or abroad
nope nope what does she mean she means
that if you defend israel you're an
islamophobe
that's what she means that is the logic
here that if you are pro-israel in a
conflict between israel and an actual
honest-to-god islamist terrorist group
then this means you're an islamophobe
and so we can count that as islamophobia
on the same level as people who are just
attacking jews in the streets
who by the way those jews i mean let's
be let's be real about this those jews
probably support israel so probably
their islamophobic so kind of they
deserve it
jamal bowman did the same thing we've
seen an increase in anti-semitic and
islamophobic hate in new york city and
nationwide and it's not just them
it's over and over and over okay there
are
dozens of congress people who are doing
this congresswoman marie newman
is anti-semitic and islamophobic attacks
across the united states
julian castro he says forcefully condemn
anti-spedic and islamophobic attacks
where are the islamophobic attacks
seriously where it
has have there have there been incidents
that we are unaware of nationally
on this leslie and brandt same sort of
deal
this is the shtick okay the shtick is
that we are going to pretend
that uh rising anti-semitic attacks has
always increased
it's always driven by a rise in
islamophobia that's truly
what lies at the root of all of this
okay so that's what's happening
at a democratic party institutional
level is they've decided to buy into the
intersectional logic
that means that if you believe that
israel is not wrong in this conflict and
has a right and a duty to defend its own
citizenry
or let's face it if you were a yamaka
well you know
if the intersection i mean you are kinda
white you are kinda white and israel is
kinda powerful
so that you can't be a victim probably
you're more like a victimizer probably
and then they wonder why anti-semitism
is rising get rid of the cops get rid of
the militating institutions
tell people that israel is an apartheid
terror state lie to them about that
which is an anti-semitic lie
suggests that anyone who's wearing a
yarmulke is responsible for that and
then
i wonder why this is happening i wonder
why but where's the entire left the same
left that trump
says that trump raised the temperature
and caused the tree of life synagogue
shooting
okay even though the guy who committed
that shooting was overtly
anti-trump doesn't matter trump raised
the temperature and his language was bad
and i
back in 2015 pointed out that trump
winking and nodding at the all right was
a terrible terrible thing okay but
these are the same people who suggested
that trump was the real anti-semite oh
trump's
the most pro-israel president in
american history he's the real
anti-semite
meanwhile they're supporting open
anti-semite anti-open somatic attacks
open anti-semitism congress people who
hate jews
and we're supposed and or going silent
being like chuck schumer uh every so
often i'll tweet something out chuck
schumer
check with that pathetic hypocrite chuck
schumer a man who used to go around the
city of new york explaining to people
that his last name schumer
came from the hebrew chomir which meant
that he would be a guardian of israel
yeah where is he anywhere nah he's
running scared because maybe aoc is
going to primary him
pathetic meanwhile you see the
international agenda being pursued by
the biden administration
which frankly i'm surprised that they
held out as long as they did before
telling israel to stop
with regard to to knocking out hamas
when we get to the international agenda
the the broader
international agenda is fomenting hamas
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about protecting
yourself so as you may
notice i'm pretty concerned about
protecting myself these days
which is why i own a bevy of weapons
it's also why i have ar 500 armor
people all over the country are buying
body armor from air 500 armor because
they offer armor selection for everyone
whether you want armor for discreet use
in public or something more robust for
protection while you're hunting or at
the shooting range
owning body armor is becoming synonymous
with owning a firearm and it should be
the second amendment protects both arms
and armor body armor
is purely defensive some armor is so
discreet nobody even knows that you are
wearing it air 500 armor makes buying
body armor super
super easy approachable affordable you
can buy it online have it shipped
directly to your house plus i know the
people who
run ar 500 armor and these are people
who really do share your values it's
pretty fantastic best of all
they've put together some packages
specifically for listeners of the daily
wire so there's something for everyone
at ar500armor.com
go to ar500arm.com to see all their
promotions and special packages running
right now you can use code ben
for twenty percent off anything else in
their entire store plan right now for
how to protect yourself and your family
for the future
get yourself the body armor we trust
from ar 500 armor at ar500 armor dot com
slash ben again visit air 500 armor.com
ben use codeben
at checkout for 20 off alrighty we're
going to get to
the bizarre iran policy of the biden
administration in just one second first
if you missed yesterday's episode of the
ben shapiro show sunday special you
should catch up i sat down with david
horowitz ex marxist conservative founder
of the david
horowitz freedom center it's a really
interesting conversation we agree on
some stuff we disagree on some stuff but
david is an interesting thinker
go check it out right now at
dailywire.com or on my youtube channel
ben shapiro
daily wire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday special
episodes so don't miss out
join daily wire today as i'm sure you
all know the daily wire has been growing
like crazy not only did we move the
whole company across the country
we also released our first feature film
we have a movie deal with gina carano we
launched a new talk show hosted by
candace owens we did all of that in the
last six months and we have such
good stuff on the way for you let me
tell you such good stuff now i want to
thank you guys for your help because you
make it all possible
you're the ones who are subscribing
you're the ones who are consuming our
content and
we want to make that content even better
for you so every day on the show you
hear me talk about a lot of amazing
products and services from sponsors
i love and use but we want to get to
know what you want better so we can
actually choose our sponsors to tailor
the message to you so please go to
dailywire.com
shapiro fill out my audience survey tell
us a little bit more about yourself to
sweeten that whole experience those of
you who complete the survey will be
entered to win a 1 000
gift card you can only take the survey
once per daily wire show so if you want
to increase your chances of winning a
thousand bucks go listen to michael
knowles andrew clavin or matt walsh get
access to their surveys as well again
my survey link is dailywire.com shapiro
we would love to hear from you
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile the biden administration
they are making some of the right moves
they are saying some of the right things
so for example the the biden
administration joe biden put out a
statement today he said the recent
attacks on the jewish community are
despicable and they must stop i condemn
this hateful behavior at home and abroad
it's up to all of us to give hafe
hate no safe harbor so good for him
that's an actual statement as opposed to
all the rest of these pathetic democrats
who are putting out statements about
anti-semitism and
islamophobia again it's it's a pretty
incredible thing from the same people
who are very concerned about the phrase
all lives matter
right when someone say black lives
matter and somebody else would say allah
is my big how dare you you're devaluing
our movement
the same people are like anti-semitism
and islamophobia now at least all lives
matter
was rejecting the basic contention that
black people were being specifically
singled out
for harsh treatment by the police with
regard to being murdered by the cops
okay that's a statistical reality but
when it comes to anti-semitism there is
a radical uptick in anti-semitism and
these same democrats are like yeah and
also islamophobia
which is the same way they shied away
from melanoma being a radical
anti-semite last year
when they were like we condem
anti-semitism and also all these other
forms of hatred and everything bad in
the universe
baffling with bullcrap anyway the biden
administration saying the right things
on anti-semitism the biden
administration
suggesting israel had a right and a duty
to protect itself last week so they did
a lot better on this than i thought they
were going to
meanwhile however they are indeed
pursuing bad policy with regard to the
iranian regimes the iran
regime is the the state it is the
sponsor state of hamas
hamas admits that they got all of their
technology from iran
and hamas acknowledges that that iran
backed them
and in fact iran cheered the attacks
according to the new york times
tehran jumped at the chance to portray
militants barrages on israel as revenge
for israeli attacks on iran the
leadership of iran engaged in a long
shadow war with israel on land aaron c
did not try to conceal the pleasure it
took in the most recent
israeli-palestinian conflict
tehran praised the damage being done to
its enemy state news media and
conservative commentators highlighted
iran's role
in providing weaponry and military
training to palestinian militants in
gaza to hammer israeli communities so
iran is making no
no bones about the fact that it supports
hamas meanwhile hamas is acknowledging
that they openly commit war crimes
right here is hamas's spokesperson on
sky news basically saying yeah sure we
commit war crimes
any people under occupation based on the
international law have the
all the right to defend themselves by
all
feasible means they have not by firing
rockets from a civilian population
i have said it clearly palestinians as
even occupied people have the right to
defend themselves
by all feasible means including our
resistance but when it comes
to civilians we have said that many
times we are ready to stop
firing rockets or attacking civilians
if this is stopped attacking our people
it's unbelievable so he's saying openly
right this is
the spokesperson remember this is this
is the government that people are
supporting
when you say i support the palestinians
in the palestinian-israeli conflict
you don't mean the palestinian people
unless you also want to get rid of hamas
but you don't want to get rid of hamas
so what am i left to conclude
okay they're openly saying that they
fire rockets from civilian areas at
civilians
they say this sort of stuff openly
they're not hiding the ball here
meanwhile even despite the ceasefire
hamas supporters were attacking jewish
homes outside jerusalem over the weekend
there's video of it they were literally
just firing ordinance down
from arab areas near jerusalem into the
jewish areas of jerusalem you can see it
happening they're shooting fireworks at
the jewish areas in jerusalem
oh
don't worry there's moral equivalence
you shoot you shoot randomly rockets at
uh an ordinance at jewish homes right
these are civilians you're not military
targets
shouting allahu akbar that's exactly the
same as the israelis targeting
military infrastructure in any case how
has the the
biden administration responded to the
fact that hamas an iran-backed terrorist
group
just committed a vast act of terrorism
against america's ally israel
uh blinken says we have to cut a deal
with iran here's tony blinken the
secretary of state
many of these actions are going forward
now uh while the uh you know and have
gone forward over the last few years
under the so-called maximum pressure uh
being exerted
by the by the previous administration
and clearly did not get the result that
we all seek
which is to curb all of these activities
but the first thing that we need to do
is put the nuclear problem back in the
box that's why we're committed to trying
to
see if iran will come back into
compliance with the nuclear agreement
the so-called jcpoa
that's what we're engaged in now the lie
that the biden administration is talking
about here
is they say well if we get them back in
the nuclear box we'll stop them from the
terrorism except that's not what they do
okay the jcpoa did not stop iran from
formatting terrorism how do you think
hamas got all these rockets
hamas was having its stockpiles built up
more rapidly before
trump pulled out of the jcpoa then after
the jcpoa was ended
and hamas hamas all these terrorist
groups get support from iran when iran
has more money they spend the money on
terrorism john kerry admitted as much
after cutting the iran deal in the first
place well israel understands
that it has to rely on itself in large
measure here which is why there was a
giant blast
an iranian complex housing their drone
factory so israel shot down
in iranian armed drone the other day and
mysteriously a complex that houses a
factory that makes iranian drones
now suffered a major explosion the blast
at the weekend in
over the weekend injured at least nine
workers at the petrochemical factory
in isfahan iran aircraft manufacturing
industrial company which produces a
variety of aircraft and drones
for iranian and pro-iranian forces is
located in the complex
iran has not provided information on the
cause of the incident but
israel of course has carried out
significant strikes internal to iran
meanwhile
speaking of the the supposed
non-radicalism of
palestinians on the temple mount
remember according to ilhan omar and
rashida talib and everyone else lying
about the situation in israel
this is all kicked off by israelis
attacking palestinians on the temple
mount which is insane
and i've been up on the temple mount
jews have to be guarded
by police forces as they are ushered
through the holy site in judaism
meanwhile arabs have free reign on the
temple mount because it is effectively
run
by the islamic walk al-aqsa was being
used as a staging ground for attacks on
jewish police officers
so even after this there's a vast video
emerging like
after the ceasefire of people attacking
police officers on the temple mount in
fact
videos on social media have shown
believe it or not
that members of the hundreds of
palestinians inside
the al-aqsa mosque were cheering
the the for they forced out the
jerusalem grand mufti okay jerusalem
grand mufti's got a muhammad hussein
he works for the palestinian authority
hey and supporters inside al-aqsa
forced him to leave while shouting we
are
muhammad df's men muhammad df is the
terror head of hamas
they're chatting they're chanting this
inside a mosque a very peaceful and
religious place
i remember the last time inside a
synagogue we started chanting for
support of terrorism but
apparently this is common practice
inside all ox of these days
so they're chanting about how they are
muhammad dave's men
don't worry everything is fine
everything and you know what moral
equivalence
up to wazoo and also it's about
anti-semitism and also islamophobia
man you know it's it's there are certain
conflicts in uh in ideology
where things sort of crystallize and
honestly if you have a tough time with
this one i've got to question your moral
bona fides if you have a real tough time
questioning the difference between
an israeli government that attempts to
minimize civilian casualties and a hamas
government that attempts to maximize
them
between an israeli population that is
attempting to co-exist with an
internal israeli arab population and
treat those israeli arabs as full
citizens with full rights
and an arab world that treats jews not
only as second-class citizens but
i mean jews do not exist effectively
speaking inside the arab world
and inside the muslim world more
specifically if you are somebody who has
a tough time just saying anti-semitic
attacks are bad regardless of
the source of the anti-semitic attacks i
do have to question
your ability to perform basic moral math
and the democratic party increasingly
cannot perform basic moral math good for
joe biden for at least doing some of it
but i fear that joe biden is not the way
of the democratic party future
i was there in 2012 when when antonio
veragosa who was heading up the
democratic national convention
actively overrode a voice vote and
allowed the the
democratic national committee platform
to include
the idea that jerusalem was was the
capital of the jewish state
i was there when when he basically there
was a voice vote on it he lost the voice
would he just overrode them
i remember this vividly and now you have
200 democrats
who voted in the house not to cut off
funding to groups that fund hamas
so yeah the future of the democratic
party does look a lot more like
the squad and like jamal bowman and like
aoc
and like ilhan omar and rashida talib in
terms of their anti-semitic attacks
on the jewish state and by extension a
certain level of tacit support for
anti-semites in the united states
and sometimes not so tacit i mean aoc
was meeting with with jeremy corbyn
i fear for the people talk about they
fear for the future of the republican
party because of trump and
authoritarianism and all this
the the party that that i fear right now
is not the republican party and it is
not
close when it comes to being a jew in
america the party i fear is the party
that has been poo pooing
playing up and and minimizing the impact
of
anti-semitism in the united states that
is a scary scary thing as a jew living
in the united states who wears a yamaka
proudly and will continue
to do so all right we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show where he discusses
the story of teen vogue
teaching young girls how to perform
witchcraft with their bodily fluids
interesting you can hear more details
about that story over on michael's show
that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sci events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
dr fatchi reverses his stance on kovid's
origins lebron james flops and teen
vogue teaches young girls how to perform
witchcraft with their bodily fluids
check it out on the michael noll show